welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz we are back with
another 15 minutes of a mentor
episode and in this really short series
we're asking some of the mentors from
inside the recruitment mentors community
seven questions in 15 minutes really
excited to be joined by
kate today but before we go into the
questions
okay if you could introduce yourself um
for those that may not know who you are
and then we'll get into it yeah sure um
so
my name's kate i have been in
recruitment for
nine years now um i specialize in
permanent placements i
have worked in a variety of marketplaces
from engineering through to biotech
and life sciences and
have had a very varied sort of number of
roles from
recruitment consultant through to team
leader and business manager
um and now i am um
sort of establishing our executive
search function in the uk um
working in the life science and biotech
sectors
amazing so what i'd love i know we're
just talking about this a bit before but
like
what i'd love to hear from you is sort
of firstly what what were your biggest
challenges
in 2020 and how you sort of did your
best to overcome them and what you
learned from them
sure okay so um it's quite a personal
one i suppose my biggest challenge in in
2020 was
um actually returning to work from
maternity leave um
into the middle of a global pandemic
and also into a new role in a new market
so
um i guess more relatable would be the
new market
so building a new market in in the
pandemic so
um how i kind of overcame
that challenge was um making sure that i
set myself
sort of you know daily and weekly um
goals that i wanted to achieve be that
like a number of
meetings that i wanted to secure with
clients or candidate conversations and
i'm really um sticking to the basics
that
you know i learned all those years ago
when i first started eyeing recruitment
um and and making sure that i was quite
rigid
in my approach in terms of you know my
like
my daily organization and the tasks that
i was sort of setting myself
because i think anyone who's building a
new market
um will know there's a lot of rejection
out there there's lots of sort of
um days and where sometimes you feel
like
i'm not getting anywhere so
yeah i think the the biggest thing i
sort of did to overcome it
it's not really um a huge crazy
new way of recruiting but it was just
kind of being
you know consistent in my approach um
and i'm really trying to celebrate the
small wins be that
you know um securing a meeting with a
client like i said
and it might not always be sort of
coming away with a with a
vacancy but if it's you know an
introduction and a pledge to maybe work
together down the line
then feeling good about those sort of
smaller wins
nice amazing so i'm sure this is
something that you've
this has been an ongoing journey for you
but i'd love to
hear sort of what working from home tip
you could share that with other
recruiters listen to this that you felt
has had a
big impact on your own productivity at
home
yeah i think for me um has been
trying to get out so get outside at
lunchtime
um and then i don't know whether that
sort of answers your question but like
trying to take your time away from my
laptop um
at least sort of just for half an hour
at lunch just to walk go for a walk and
i feel like if i do that i know
obviously the weather's not always great
but if i do that then that sort of sets
me up to
have like a productive morning and and
having a productive afternoon because it
sort of
sets um my day up whereas when i first
came back to work i'm not going to lie i
would spend just the whole day
at my laptop yeah yeah not really taking
like
any kind of structured time away from
the screen
and i was really kind of getting to the
end of the day and then like
as i sort of mentioned to you before i
you know go and get my daughter from
nursery and then
come home get her to bed and then i'd be
logging back on and
really i'd be like on my laptop pretty
much consistently from like 8 a.m till
10 p.m
um easy done isn't it i think yeah
so yeah so introducing small habits like
kind of getting outdoors at lunch time
um and
also um yeah just setting
i guess even like 10 minutes to go
downstairs and get a coffee
and then i think you'll probably notice
yourself when we last spoke
um i was in my kitchen downstairs
i've now kind of retreated upstairs we
don't have a sort of
an office space but i've made myself
like you know got a desk and everything
up here
um it actually kind of feels a little
bit like going to work now as well
it's a dedicated space yeah yeah yeah
and you know like
um it kind of makes the day feel like
right i've come up here to work now and
then like
i go back downstairs then i'm getting a
defined breakaway because i was as i
said i was spending all my time in that
space
which is also like in our home anyway
like quite a social space like it's our
living space it's a big kind of kitchen
area dining area so
yeah the days and the days and the work
and non-work time was very blurred in
the beginning
put those sort of things into place nice
so so my next question is
sort of what's been the most effective
way for you to win business in the last
12 months so i know it may not be a
full-time month but
maybe you can sort of just think about
what what's um being the most impactful
in terms of as you've been building out
this new market since you've been back
so
what's been sort of the best way for you
to win business and client develop um
since you've been building out the new
market um
you know what i think actually going
and introducing myself to businesses
and actually taking the approach of um
introducing like myself and my services
more broadly
rather than like kind of going in trying
to sort of
win a vacancy or like introduce a
one particular candidate i think when we
did my um
presentation you know before or the
mentoring session i talked about having
something interesting to like discuss
with
with clients be a candidate or like um
you know how you can sort of add value
so
i think the main thing i've found is is
just sort of
um being more
open to going in and offering a more
broader solution rather than trying to
fix perhaps like one problem vacancy
now i know obviously everyone has
specialist areas that they cover
but if you're just going in and saying
oh i've got a candidate for this one
vacancy
then you're quite limited into what you
can offer the client um
whereas if you take that approach that
you you know you're
more interested in in um obviously
partnering with them longer term and and
giving them a longer term solution then
that's been really helpful
um and also just sort of you know
um reaching out via email obviously i
don't have mobile numbers like everyone
does in here like
a brand new and an established patch so
um yeah i found actually like if i'm
i've not really been having loads of
wins calling up the switchboard no one's
working in the office
and so so it's yeah just been sort of
sending introductory
emails and linkedin um
follow-ups and and i think that's going
on to that following up and i think i
talked to you about that before is
is making sure that you do follow up on
the businesses that you want to work
with um if you've got your target client
list don't just try and get through to
them once
or twice and then like that's it um
really consistently making your approach
and
um yeah i've found that's been
nice yeah so yeah i think it's it's
definitely
under underrated or underspoke about how
how great how important it is to be able
to write like good email
copy and things like that and i've sort
of tried to spend time reading about it
and stuff i just think find it super
interesting but it's something that you
can definitely improve
i think sometimes people sort of miss
that um
okay interesting so next question i'll
be interested here what
what habit of hobby did you start in
2020 that you're going to continue in
2021
work-wise or whatever that can be
personal work but just what habit or
hobby
did you maybe start i started road
cycling
yeah so i injured my knee in the first
lock down
so i i was never if my husband never
sees this he'll
die laughing i've never been a good one
um
well yeah my only and my old colleagues
see this as well i'm sure they'll find
this hilarious i'm not a good runner
um but i've always tried to get out
there for a bit of cardio and
do like you know 5k um
yeah i heard my hurt my knee in first
lockdown and so that's really kind of
not been a possible option so i started
road biking
in april i did a 50 mile
ride in oh wow yeah so that was for a
local charity
um yeah i really really
enjoyed it so that has been like my my i
guess any big
sort of bike plans this year or like big
bike rides that you've been thinking
about
i don't know i don't know well i'm
thinking i'm i'm obvious so this
again i've said that i've put it out to
the universe that i've got
i'm not i'm not very good at the cold
weather cycling so
with we were excessive like deciding
whether we're going to get like a turbo
trainer
okay i i think so that we can do that i
could do some more indoor stuff
during i've actually that's actually
come out when i've asked this question
quite a few people have um invested in
those and and i have spoken really
highly of them
actually which is really interesting
people have
gone i've become like i'm doing a
marathon this year or i'm really going
to my running or they've really got into
their psych then
wow we're all so boring and predictable
yeah i'm also up to my cooking game a
lot
probably another obvious one um we we do
gusto now so like i feel like we eat
like loads more
varied food which has been great um
yeah that's the two things
so probably the most important question
um
which you think is better the first
coffee in the morning or the first pint
post work on a friday
so maybe this is a new me versus an old
me
mummy is definitely the coffee in the
morning
and that is definitely a 2020 to 2021
habit change
um previously it was definitely the beer
on the friday afternoon
um and i'm sure of like you know i know
you're in touch with
quite a few people that i know so i'm
sure that if they see this they'll be
like
what all right so yeah
i'll say i have to say now it is
definitely the coffee first thing in the
morning
um i don't know so so next question is
slightly different
it's just more of a scenario that i'd
love to sort of hear
how you do how you'd approach it so so
this narrow is
a particular business that you've had on
your target client list for a long
period of time
and during that time you've had several
touch points with different
people different hiring managers in that
company so
they may have received an email from you
you might drop them a note on um
linkedin then maybe even engage with
some of your content but there's
definitely been different touch points
and but through your candidate network
you manage to get one of the hiring
managers contact details
so you call that hiring manager they
pick up say hello who is this and
we just love to hear how you'd approach
that sort of initial interaction with
a hiring manager at a business that
you're you've sort of prospected or
would
love the opportunity to work with okay
um
first question before i give you an
answer do am i able to
sort of utilize the candidate that's
given me absolutely
okay so yeah go into the call and
say like hi um sorry you know to call
you about the bloom
it's kate from vantage and we've kind of
been in touch in various
methods previously but actually um
i got past your details by so and so
um the reason i'm reaching out is i
really wanted to
talk to you about recruitment within
your business
i've got nine years experience in your
area and and sort of introduced my
specialism from there
um and i'm sort of want to understand
more about how we could potentially work
together in
going forward because i'd really love to
to work with your business
nice yeah so it's a lead with candidate
get credibility in there yeah yeah
i think if you can it's great to be able
to so going back to some of the things
you talked about winning business before
so one of the
um a really great piece of work that i
was lucky to do
before christmas um came in that way so
a candidate that i was dealing with um
gave me the contact details of ceo of a
client now
um and so i just reached out and just
sort of
introduced myself on the phone and just
sort of suggested to her that this
particular person had shared her
her details with me and you know
straight away she was
fine luckily they had done so um i
checked with the candidate first i think
that's really important if you are going
to do that
they were happy for me to reference them
in that introduction
um and that's important isn't that
official yeah
so i did that and and um yeah luckily it
it led to three placements so it was a
good a good intro so if you can use
your candidate network then absolutely
like
yeah do it all the time get the
recommendations but i think um
yeah it's always a warmer call if you
can utilize that that lead in but if you
can't
i think um you know just sort of say
look
um through networking i i have been past
your details
um and you know i think i've spoken with
other people within the business and
i understand that you're hiring and i'm
really
you know confident that um i would be
able to add value to hiring process and
sort of introduce yourself that way
most of the time people are fine if you
do call them and
you know you've got your their number
from somewhere i think it's what you
said right i think it's having that
mindset of like
yeah thinking about the bigger picture
rather than really
sort of doing everything you can to try
and get that one job
um so so final question
is i want you to sort of imagine that
you're speaking to recruiters listening
to this podcast who has set their goals
for 2021
they've written them down they're
feeling super motivated they're
completely convinced they're gonna have
a better year than they did
last year um and i would just love to
hear your advice on what you
sort of would say to that person that
you think would give them the best
possible chance of
achieving their goals yeah okay i think
i really like this question um i think
if you're you know
super ambitious and organized and sort
of sitting down and
got clear goals that you want to achieve
um
how often you know you review those
goals
and that is really important so have you
kind of broken it down into like
smaller goals to kind of reach the
larger goals within the
your yearly target um and also not just
sort of i guess
looking at it from a perspective of by
the end of the year i want to hit this
i don't know monetary figure or i want
to hit this promotion target
um and then hoping that because you've
written it down at the beginning of the
year that you're going to do so
i think you have to really make sure
that you set time aside in your in your
in your diary um i would suggest at
least monthly to review how you're
getting on with those goals
and putting an action plan in place i
think like everything
put well personally your kind of targets
and goals kind of
um evolve as time passes um but if you
have like a defined time scale and you
know
are really holding yourself accountable
to what you want to achieve
um then i i'd say that's probably from
my experience the best way that you're
going to
achieve those goals is by regularly
checking in with yourself
um because i think we all set out really
well intentioned and i think it goes
back to what i was saying before about
being organized and structured when you
you know when i was starting out in this
new market
um you know we say oh yeah i'm going to
go and conquer the world and take on all
these big events and
be the best in the market but if you
don't regularly set yourself time aside
to review where you're at with that
process
um i think it can kind of like fall by
the wayside
so yeah no awesome great advice
okay that was 15 minutes of a mental
thank you thanks very much